From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm David Kestenbaum, sitting in for Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆，代班艾拉·格拉斯。
This morning on the subway, this guy brought his own chair.
今天早上在地铁上，有个家伙自带了一把椅子。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I was sitting next to him, but he was in a foldout chair.
我就坐在他旁边，他坐的是一把折叠椅。
That's Aviva DeKornfeld, apparently our transportation correspondent. She came in to the studio to tell me a story about a woman on a bus ride that went very strangely.
那是阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德，看来她是我们的交通通讯员。她来到演播室，给我讲了一个关于一位女士在公交车上经历的非常离奇的故事。
Her name's Duck. Or that's her nickname. That's what we're going to call her. She takes this bus between New York and DC a lot, back and forth. So on this trip, she's going from New York to DC, Union Station. And she's leaving around 6:00 PM at night. And she has this whole routine around the bus because she's done this trip a million times. This is Duck.
她叫达克（Duck），或者这是她的昵称。我们就这样称呼她。她经常往返于纽约和华盛顿特区之间坐这趟巴士。这次旅行，她正从纽约前往华盛顿特区的联合车站。她大约在晚上6点出发。因为这趟路她坐过无数次，所以对这趟巴士有一整套固定的流程。这就是达克。
Then I'll go get a margarita, get on the bus, take a nap, wake up back home in DC. I boarded the bus as normal. They checked me in. The guy had the app with all the passengers. He made a little announcement. And they even-- I remember distinctly, they said, there's no stops planned. Great.
然后我会去买杯玛格丽特酒，上车，打个盹，醒来时就回到华盛顿特区的家里了。我像往常一样上了车。他们核对了我的信息。那个人拿着有所有乘客名单的应用程序。他做了一个简短的广播。我记得很清楚，他们当时说，没有计划停靠站。太棒了。
Are you good at sleeping on public transit?
你很擅长在公共交通工具上睡觉吗？
I can pretty much sleep anywhere.
我基本上能在任何地方睡觉。
Oh my god, you're so lucky.
天哪，你太幸运了。
My parents would always joke that I could sleep through anything.
我父母总是开玩笑说我能在任何情况下睡着。
So she goes to sleep. And then she wakes up around 9:00 PM to a bunch of commotion. And all the passengers are talking on the bus about what's going on. And what's going on is really odd, and so odd that Duck starts writing a thread about this online, which is how I heard about it. Here's the first post she writes.
于是她睡着了。大约晚上9点，她被一阵骚动吵醒。所有的乘客都在巴士上议论发生了什么事。发生的事情真的很奇怪，奇怪到达克开始在网上写关于这件事的帖子，我就是这么知道的。这是她写的第一篇帖子。
I just woke up from a nap, and somehow, while I was asleep, everyone on the bus has figured out that we are not going to the right place.
我刚从午睡中醒来，不知何故，在我睡觉的时候，车上的每个人都发现我们没去对地方。
Aviva, do they think there's a mistake or something?
阿维瓦，他们觉得是出了什么错吗？
Well, the driver of the bus is apparently telling passengers, like, I'm not going to the wrong place. You're on the wrong bus. This bus isn't going to Washington, DC. It's going further south to Virginia. And we're not going to stop. So Duck writes another post.
嗯，巴士司机显然是在告诉乘客，他说，我没去错地方。是你们上错车了。这辆车不是去华盛顿特区的。它是去更南边的弗吉尼亚州。而且我们不会停。于是达克又写了一篇帖子。
He's refusing to talk to anyone while he's driving and is now driving really fast. I think this is when the attitude on the bus starts to turn a little bit towards maybe we're not in a safe situation.
他在开车时拒绝和任何人交谈，而且现在开得非常快。我想就是这个时候，车上的气氛开始变得有点让人觉得我们的处境可能不安全。
And what do they think is going on? Like, is it possible they just got on the wrong bus?
他们觉得发生了什么？比如，有没有可能他们只是上了错的车？
No, because every person on the bus has been checked in by the driver as going to Washington, DC.
没有，因为车上的每个人都被司机核对过是去华盛顿特区的。
And all their tickets say to DC.
而且他们所有的票上都写着去华盛顿特区。
Yeah.
是的。
So this is the situation. They're all basically trapped on a bus. And the driver is not doing what bus drivers have typically done in the history of bus driving. I'm not sure exactly how to say this, but, whatever you think of President Trump, maybe this is a feeling you have been experiencing? He's made hundreds of millions of dollars selling meme coins to his fans and other people. He is bombing boats off Venezuela. He's tearing down the East Wing and building a giant ballroom.
所以情况就是这样。他们基本上都被困在车上了。而那个司机做的事，是巴士驾驶史上典型的巴士司机不会做的事。我不确定该怎么说，但是，无论你对特朗普总统有什么看法，也许这就是你一直以来的感受？他靠卖表情包代币给粉丝和其他人赚了数亿美元。他在委内瑞拉炸毁船只。他拆掉了东翼，正在建一个巨大的宴会厅。
Maybe this makes you feel like everything's out of control. Or maybe you're fine with it. Maybe the bus driver is a genius, and you think we should all just sit back and see. In this case, though, the passengers are not into it. And when a person has so completely left the normal script of things, the question is, what do you do?
也许这让你觉得一切都失控了。或者你觉得无所谓。也许这个巴士司机是个天才，你认为我们应该坐下来拭目以待。但在这种情况下，乘客们并不买账。当一个人完全脱离了正常的行事准则，问题就是，你该怎么办？
So the first thing they try to do is reason with the bus driver, reassert the normal facts and rules for the bus ride. Duck said that two guys went up to him at the front of the bus and said, man to man, we're going to Union Station.
所以他们首先尝试的是与巴士司机讲道理，重申巴士旅行的正常事实和规则。达克说，有两个人走到车头，以男人的方式对他说，老兄，我们是要去联合车站。
And?
然后呢？
He said, no, we're not. Didn't work.
他说，不，我们不去。没用。
What do they try next?
他们接下来试了什么？
After that, someone notices that he has a French accent and thinks, oh, maybe this is a language barrier issue. So they start talking to him in French and then end up arguing with him in French. And then it becomes very clear it is not a language barrier issue.
之后，有人注意到他有法国口音，就想，哦，也许是语言障碍问题。于是他们开始用法语和他交谈，最后甚至用法语和他争论。然后很明显，这根本不是语言障碍问题。
Wow.
哇。
And then Duck just starts firing off post after post. And you can feel things escalating as you're reading the thread. And it's like, first, the bus company is trying to call the driver, and he's not answering. And then someone pulls up Waze and sees that they're going 20 miles over the speed limit. And then someone gets the bus company on speakerphone and is walking it up to the front of the bus. And then Duck could actually hear the bus company guy yelling, you're going to Union Station, to the bus driver. And then he screams in response that he doesn't get paid enough and is refusing.
然后达克就开始接二连三地发帖。当你读那个帖子时，你能感觉到事态在升级。就像，起初是巴士公司试图联系司机，但他不接听。然后有人打开Waze导航看到他们超速了20英里。然后有人把巴士公司的人连线到免提电话上，走到了车头。然后达克真的听到了巴士公司的人对着司机大喊，你要去联合车站。作为回应，他尖叫着说他挣的钱不够，并拒绝听从。
Wow.
哇。
And then person after person-- each kind of feels like they're going to be the hero who convinces the bus driver to get back on track. And so each person takes their phone with the company reps on speakerphone to the bus driver. And then in response, he just grabs them and hangs up.
然后一个人接着一个人——每个人似乎都觉得他们会成为说服巴士司机回到正轨的英雄。于是每个人都拿着开着免提的电话去找司机。作为回应，他只是夺过手机挂断了。
Why don't they call the police?
为什么他们不报警？
Well, so then that is the next thing that people are thinking about doing. So while a couple passengers are in the front of the bus, fighting with the driver, the rest of the people in the back of the bus are debating whether or not to call the police. Because half the bus is thinking this is actually just going to agitate him further, and that feels dangerous. And the other half are like, well, the bus company can't help us. So who is the next authority figure who can come to our help?
嗯，这正是人们接下来考虑的事情。所以，当几个乘客在车头和司机争执时，车厢后面的人在争论是否要报警。因为半车人认为这只会让他更加烦躁，那感觉很危险。而另一半人则认为，既然巴士公司帮不了我们，那还有哪位权威人物能来救我们？
So what happens?
后来发生了什么？
Eventually, someone does call the police. And Duck's next post is, quote, "OK. Someone called the police but suggested they avoid pulling over the bus because he's driving so erratically. We are passing DC."
最终，有人确实报了警。达克接下来的帖子是，引用：“好吧。有人报了警，但建议他们不要拦停巴士，因为他开车太不稳定了。我们正在经过华盛顿特区。”
So they feel like they're in danger?
所以他们觉得他们有危险？
The bus is kind of split. Half the bus feels like they're in the sequel to the movie Speed.
车上的情况有点分裂。半车人觉得自己像是在电影《生死时速》的续集里。
Like they're being kidnapped or something.
就像他们被绑架了一样。
Yes. And then the other half feels like, you know what? Let's just sit tight, see what happens.
是的。而另一半人则觉得，你知道吗？我们就安分守己，看会发生什么吧。
In the dark at, like, 75 miles an hour on some highway.
在黑暗中以每小时75英里的速度在高速公路上飞驰。
Yes.
是的。
It's like they tried all these things, and now there's nothing else they can do.
感觉他们尝试了所有这些方法，现在什么也做不了了。
There's a good bit of wanting the situation to be otherwise and wanting it to be easily figureoutable in the moment and not having to wait for something bad to happen or wait to figure out how it all resolves.
这其中有一种心理，就是希望情况不是这样，希望这件事当下就能轻易解决，而不是等着坏事发生，或者等着看这一切如何收场。
Yeah. And then at some point, you're like, well, I guess we just have to-- it's actually up to him.
是的。然后在某个时刻，你会觉得，好吧，我想我们只能——这实际上取决于他。
We have to go on this entire bus ride, no matter where it ends.
无论终点在哪里，我们都必须完成这段巴士旅程。
So he does eventually get off the highway in Vienna, Virginia.
所以他最终在弗吉尼亚州的维也纳下了高速公路。
Like he promised.
像他承诺的那样。
And he does, weirdly, sort of go through the normal motions of a bus driver at a bus stop. And he helps everyone get off and get their luggage from underneath the bus, and-- although people are yelling at him, and he's kind of yelling back. And he's flipping people off. And then once everyone's off, he just drives off.
而且很奇怪的是，他确实走了一遍巴士司机在公交站的正常流程。他帮每个人下车并从车底取出行李，虽然人们在对他大喊大叫，他也回敬对方。他还向人们竖中指。一旦所有人都下车了，他就直接开走了。
Did they ever get an answer to what was going on with the guy?
他们有没有得到关于那个家伙到底是怎么回事的解释？
No. But the bus company did send another bus to Virginia to pick them up and take them back to DC. And that bus driver was very apologetic and was like, sorry about that other guy. I think he's new.
没有。但巴士公司确实派了另一辆车到弗吉尼亚接他们，把他们带回了华盛顿特区。那个巴士司机非常抱歉，他说，为那个人感到抱歉。我想他是新来的。
I think he's new?
我想他是新来的？
Yes, which does not seem like the behavior of a new bus driver to me. But--
是的，这在我看来不像是一个新巴士司机的行为。但是……
But they made it home?
但他们安全到家了吗？
Yes. They made it home.
是的。他们到家了。
We did reach out to the bus company. A spokesperson said the driver does not work there anymore. He had disobeyed his supervisor's instructions. Quote, "As to what caused him to do so, we are not sure."
我们确实联系了巴士公司。一位发言人说，那个司机已经不在那里工作了。他违背了主管的指示。引用：“至于是什么导致他这样做，我们也不确定。”
Duck said that the bus ride from Vienna, Virginia, back to DC, their original destination, was very quiet.
达克说，从弗吉尼亚州维也纳回华盛顿特区（他们最初的目的地）的这段路非常安静。
Today on the show, people who find themselves on journeys they did not intend or agree to. They find themselves trapped on these journeys, and they have to figure out what to do. In one story, a famous tree disappears from a landscape overnight. Also, one woman's shockingly difficult quest to get some badly needed-ice cubes. Stay with us.
今天的节目，关于那些发现自己踏上了非本意或未同意旅程的人们。他们发现自己被困在这些旅程中，不得不设法解决。在一个故事中，一棵著名的树在一夜之间从风景中消失了。此外，一位女性为了得到急需的冰块，进行了一场令人震惊的艰难探索。请留下来。
It's This American Life. Act One, The Gardener. Sometimes the bus ride you're stuck on, against your will, is the thoughts that are spinning around in your own mind. Ayman Oghanna has a story like that. He's a reporter who's been on our show before, does his stories from a lot of different countries and conflict zones. Here he is.
这是《美国生活》。第一幕，园丁。有时，你被迫陷入的巴士旅程，是你自己脑中不断旋转的思绪。艾曼·奥甘纳（Ayman Oghanna）有一个这样的故事。他是一位记者，以前也上过我们的节目，在许多不同的国家和冲突地区报道过。这就是他。
My wife and I live in a sleepy seaside town on the outskirts of Athens, the kind of place where nothing interesting ever happens. She says that's why we live there. We run into our neighbors all the time in our small apartment building. Below us, two floors down, is this guy, Christos. He's a Greek air force colonel in his mid 50s, has a family-- a traditional kind of guy.
我和妻子住在雅典郊区一个安静的海滨小镇，那种从来不会发生有趣事情的地方。她说这就是我们住在那里的原因。我们经常在我们居住的小公寓楼里碰到邻居。住在我们楼下两层的是这个家伙，克里斯托斯。他是一位50多岁的希腊空军上校，有家庭，是一个传统的人。
He has this kind of clean face, bright eyes, always a little bit shy and ready to help.
他有一张干净的脸，明亮的眼睛，总是有点害羞，随时准备帮忙。
This is my wife, Klea.
这是我的妻子，克莱娅。
Like, he will always be helpful with door or with the cat, Kuku.
比如，他总是很乐意帮忙扶门或照顾猫咪库库。
Kuku is our cat. He's an indoor-outdoor cat. And to be honest, he's kind of an asshole, bites me in my sleep sometimes. But Christos is always nice to him.
库库是我们的猫。他是一只室内外通行的猫。老实说，他有点混蛋，有时会在我睡觉时咬我。但克里斯托斯对他总是很好。
So he would always be gentle with Kuku, open the door to Kuku, and say, hey, how are you? Even talk to my cat-- this is what I want to say. So the feeling I have is just this kind, trusted person in our building.
所以他总是对库库很温柔，为库库开门，说，嘿，你好吗？甚至和我的猫说话——这就是我想说的。所以我心中的感觉就是他是一个善良、值得信赖的人。
Christos shares the apartment with his wife, teenage daughter, and mother-in-law. The wife and mother-in-law, in our experience, are not so nice, the opposite of Christos, always yelling at him, causing problems in the building. When we heard Christos's family yelling at him, it always felt a bit sad. He never shouted back, never defended himself. He just absorbed it quietly.
克里斯托斯与他的妻子、十几岁的女儿和岳母住在一起。根据我们的经验，他的妻子和岳母不那么友好，和克里斯托斯完全相反，总是对他大喊大叫，在楼里制造麻烦。当我们听到克里斯托斯的家人对他大喊大叫时，总是感到有点难过。他从不反驳，从不为自己辩解。他只是默默地承受着。
In the evenings, he'd water the small vegetable patch in front of our building-- tomatoes, cabbages, peppers pushing up through dry soil. He was the most ordinary presence imaginable, until one day in February.
晚上，他会给楼前的一小块菜地浇水——番茄、卷心菜、辣椒从干涸的土地中冒出来。他曾是一个最平凡的存在，直到二月的一天。
I'll tell you how I find out about this. So I was with my mum, Chloe. And Pardis and everyone was there.
我告诉你我是怎么发现这件事的。当时我和我妈克洛伊在一起。帕迪斯和大家都在那儿。
Your family.
你的家人。
My family. So my family was there. And out of the blue, my mum says, did you find out about Christos? Did you heard what happened in the news? And I'm totally confused. I didn't know what she was talking about. And then she explains, Christos that lives in the building, he was caught by the police. He is caught by the police about what? I'm like, what? And she says, oh, yeah, he's a spy. It was like a bomb.
我的家人。所以我的家人都在那儿。突然间，我妈说，你知道关于克里斯托斯的事了吗？你听到新闻里发生了什么吗？我完全困惑了。我不知道她在说什么。然后她解释说，住在楼里的克里斯托斯，被警察抓住了。他被警察抓住是关于什么的？我说，什么？她说，哦，是的，他是间谍。那简直像是一枚炸弹。
International espionage in our little apartment building. According to news reports, the Greek intelligence service had been quietly monitoring him for months. He's accused of passing classified NATO material to China, and it may take a long time to fully assess the damage.
在我们的小公寓楼里发生了国际间谍活动。据新闻报道，希腊情报部门已经秘密监视他好几个月了。他被指控向中国传递北约机密材料，完全评估损害可能需要很长时间。
For his part, Christos has largely admitted to the charges. We reached out to him and his family. Through his lawyer, Christos said he initially thought he was working with a private company on a legitimate business opportunity. He didn't know they were actually working with the Chinese government. And gradually, he was pressured into spying. He apologized to his country, the armed forces, his colleagues, and his family. Reportedly, he's cooperating with investigators.
就克里斯托斯而言，他基本上承认了指控。我们联系了他和他的家人。通过律师，克里斯托斯说他最初以为是在与一家私营公司进行合法的商业机会合作。他不知道他们实际上是在为中国政府工作。后来，他逐渐受到压力去进行间谍活动。他向他的国家、武装部队、同事和家人道歉。据报道，他正在配合调查人员工作。
But that's not really why I'm telling you this story. I'm telling it because for years, I was convinced there were spies all around me. 10 years ago, I was diagnosed with bipolar disorder. I've had episodes of paranoia, sometimes psychosis, often involving spies. And now, here we were, with an accused spy living in our building.
但这并不是我讲这个故事的真正原因。我讲它是因为多年来，我一直坚信我周围到处都是间谍。10年前，我被诊断出患有躁郁症。我经历过偏执发作，有时是精神病，通常涉及间谍。而现在，在这里，我们的楼里住着一个被指控的间谍。
Madness doesn't arrive suddenly. It slides in quietly, like a familiar voice, whispering things you've longed to hear. My most recent episode happened a few years ago. I had just returned from a reporting trip to Israel in the occupied West Bank. It started with my phone. It seemed to be behaving strangely, overheating in my hand, apps freezing, missed calls appearing from countries I'd never been. These could all be explained, of course, if, say, I was under surveillance.
疯狂不会突然降临。它会悄悄滑入，像一个熟悉的声音，低声说着你渴望听到的话。我最近的一次发作发生在几年前。我刚从以色列占领的西岸的一趟报道旅程中回来。它始于我的手机。它似乎表现得很奇怪，在我手中过热，应用程序死机，出现我从未去过的国家的未接来电。这些都可以解释，当然，如果，比如说，我受到了监视。
Then I started noticing suspicious people-- Chinese tourists taking pictures on their phones of things that weren't particularly interesting. What about that delivery bike idling too long outside the building? One afternoon, I saw a woman in sunglasses walking the same way as me, which I took as a sign I was being followed. So I hopped on an Athens city bus. I'd given her the slip, only to find myself arriving in the airport, which is a perfect place if you're imagining international espionage-- people from all over the globe, flights from Istanbul, Vienna, Doha, strange tongues, faces, and people.
然后我开始注意到可疑的人——中国游客在手机上拍摄一些没什么特别有趣的东西。那辆在楼外怠速太久的送货自行车呢？一天下午，我看到一个戴墨镜的女人和我走同一条路，我把它视为我在被跟踪的信号。于是我跳上了一辆雅典城市巴士。我甩掉了她，结果发现自己到了机场，如果你想象着国际间谍活动，那里是一个完美的地方——来自全球各地的人，来自伊斯坦布尔、维也纳、多哈的航班，奇怪的语言、面孔和人。
But none stranger than me-- I wandered departures, slyly photographing people I thought were agents. I uploaded photos of them to Instagram to let them know I had them made. It was exhilarating. Mania can feel electric. When I was in this state, people would notice that I was off and presume I was drunk or high.
但没有比我更奇怪的了——我在出发大厅游荡，偷偷拍摄我认为是特工的人。我把他们的照片传到Instagram上，让他们知道我认出他们了。那令人振奋。躁狂症可以让人感到带电。当我处于这种状态时，人们会注意到我不对劲，认为我喝醉了或吸毒了。
Loved ones who knew me better could see something was wrong and suggested getting help. But I wouldn't listen, convinced that they were trying to lock me up in a psych ward to silence me, preventing me from carrying out my hazy mission, like I had some purpose but didn't know what it was. Soon, I was sure there were spies in the building. Weirdly, one person I did not suspect, even in psychosis, was mild-mannered Christos.
更了解我的亲人能看出不对劲，建议我去寻求帮助。但我听不进去，坚信他们想把我关进精神病院来让我闭嘴，阻止我执行我那朦胧的任务，就像我有一些目的但我不知道那是什么。很快，我确信楼里有间谍。奇怪的是，即使在精神病发作期间，我唯一没有怀疑的人，竟然是性格温和的克里斯托斯。
Klea watched me spin out. We'd recently gotten engaged, and now I was talking about spies all the time. At first, she told herself it would pass. Then she realized it might not, which was frightening. And then I disappeared. After a few days, Klea called the British Embassy and the police. They eventually found me, detained me, and took me to a mental hospital.
克莱娅看着我陷入疯狂。我们刚订婚，现在我一直在谈论间谍。起初，她告诉自己这会过去的。后来她意识到可能不会，这很可怕。然后我消失了。几天后，克莱娅给英国大使馆和警察打了电话。他们最终找到了我，拘留了我，并把我带到了精神病院。
Yeah. That was scary. It was scary. Because I was afraid you might never come back again in your stable place, that I would never see and talk to the person I remember. Oh, also, I remember this. In this madness, there were moments where you had your sanity. That was so, so weird.
是的。那很可怕。那很可怕。因为我担心你可能永远不会回到你稳定的状态了，我可能永远看不到也谈不了我记得的那个人。哦，还有，我记得这个。在这种疯狂中，有那么些时刻你保持着理智。那真是太奇怪了。
Like what?
比如什么？
Like, I remember you were at the psychiatric hospital, right? And the nurse was trying to convince you to stay stable and have your vaccine.
比如，我记得你在精神病院，对吧？护士试图说服你保持稳定并接种疫苗。
Not vaccine-- injection.
不是疫苗——是注射。
Injection, sorry-- in order for you to calm down, because the police was there. And they would had to put handcuffs in order to transport you from the public hospital to the private one. And you were in denial. You were like, I'm not doing this. So in some point, you said, I want my fiancee to come. And that's my condition. If she comes, then I'll-- so you were negotiating things. And when they were transporting you, I was with them. And you said, my love, didn't I promise you adventures? So here you are. These are the adventures.
注射，对不起——为了让你冷静下来，因为警察在场。他们必须戴上手铐才能把你从公立医院转运到私立医院。而你拒绝了。你说，我不做这个。所以在某个时候，你说，我要我的未婚妻来。这是我的条件。如果她来，那我就——所以你在谈判。当他们转运你时，我和他们在一起。你说，我的爱，我没答应过你冒险吗？所以你在这儿。这些就是冒险。
Later, she told me she'd started to wonder if I was a spy, that my obsession with espionage made more sense if I was somehow part of it. It turns out, delusions about espionage and religion are extremely common in people who have bipolar disorder. After a few weeks in hospital, I was released. Klea found a bespectacled, goateed professor of psychiatry who she hoped could help me. He introduced me to something called psychoeducation. I'd seen shrinks before but had some bad experiences.
后来，她告诉我她开始怀疑我是不是个间谍，我对间谍活动的痴迷如果我不知何故是其中的一部分，那就说得通了。事实证明，关于间谍和宗教的妄想在患有躁郁症的人中非常普遍。在医院住了几周后，我出院了。克莱娅找到了一位戴眼镜、留着山羊胡的心理学教授，她希望能帮助我。他向我介绍了一种叫“心理教育”的东西。我以前看过心理医生，但有一些糟糕的经历。
Psychoeducation was different. It taught me to learn the mechanics of my disorder the way a psychiatrist would-- what triggers look like, how symptoms stacked up, what the early warning lights were. I was less a passive patient and more a junior practitioner in my own case. I started to map my own warning signs-- a broken sleep cycle, the rush of success. I made sure to always take my meds as prescribed and guard my sleep like it was my job, especially on the days that I felt least like doing either.
心理教育是不同的。它教我像精神科医生一样了解我疾病的机制——触发因素是什么样子的，症状是如何叠加的，早期预警信号是什么。我不再是被动的病人，而是我个人案例的初级实践者。我开始绘制自己的预警信号——破碎的睡眠周期，成功的冲动。我确保始终按处方服药，并像工作一样保护我的睡眠，特别是在我最不想做这两件事的日子里。
When I sat up, typing revelations at 2:00 AM, convinced I had uncovered truth, the rule was simple-- type them out, but don't send them to anyone. Then check in daylight. Most mornings, the revelation looked like nonsense from an overheated mind. For the first few months, it was hard to admit that none of it had actually happened. I went back over it all, searching for proof that it was real, that someone really was watching me. I've learned to remind myself that coincidences do happen all the time. Everything can be a symbol if you let it.
当我在凌晨2点坐起来打字揭露真相时，确信我发现了真相，规则很简单——把它们打出来，但不要发送给任何人。然后在白天检查。大多数早晨，这些揭露看起来就像一个过热大脑的胡言乱语。头几个月，很难承认这一切其实根本没有发生。我一遍又一遍地回顾这一切，寻找证据证明它是真实的，证明确实有人在监视我。我学会了提醒自己，巧合确实一直在发生。如果你任由其发展，万物皆可成为象征。
When Klea found out Christos had been arrested, I was in Syria on a reporting trip. She was worried how I would respond to the news.
当克莱娅发现克里斯托斯被捕时，我正在叙利亚进行报道。她很担心我听到这个消息会有什么反应。
How am I going to tell Ayman that what he was telling me is true, this kind of ironic situation? My fear was like, what if I trigger you? I trigger something bad. So that was a point when I called you. And I remember you were in Syria, reporting. And I said the whole story fast. But in every sentence, I remember you were always saying, whoa, this is unbelievable. Whoa. This is unbelievable.
我怎么告诉艾曼他之前告诉我的事是真的呢，这种讽刺的情况？我的恐惧是，如果我触发了你怎么办？我触发了一些糟糕的事情。所以那是我给你打电话的时候。我记得你当时在叙利亚报道。我快速讲完了整个故事。但在每一句里，我记得你一直在说，哇，这真是难以置信。哇。这真是难以置信。
I remember standing on the hotel balcony in Syria, the phone to my ear, taking it in and thinking not just how strange it was, but that I wasn't going loopy-- no paranoia.
我记得站在叙利亚酒店的阳台上，拿着电话听着，吸收着这些信息，想的不仅是这件事有多奇怪，而且我并没有陷入疯狂——没有偏执。
The way you reacted on it was very, very-- I would say impressive-- and relief, made me feel relief. Because you got the information, you process it, and it felt like you accept it as it is, that this is reality, and your neighbor might be a spy.
你对此的反应非常非常——我会说是令人印象深刻——而且是释然，让我感到释然。因为你收到了信息，你处理了它，感觉你接受了现实，即这确实是现实，你的邻居可能真的是间谍。
I just remember how amazing it was. I felt like, yeah, OK, you're not completely crazy. Like, there are spies out there, and there's one in your building. And it felt almost like a part of me was like, yes.
我只是记得那有多么神奇。我感觉，是的，好吧，你并没有完全疯掉。就像，外面确实有间谍，而你楼里就有一个。这感觉就像我的一部分在说，是的。
[RATTLING]
[格格作响]
That's your meds.
那是你的药。
That's the reminder for my meds, which is very appropriate.
那是我的服药提醒，这非常恰当。
When I got home from Syria, I was still trying to wrap my head around the news about Christos. I went to the garden where he used to carefully water the vegetable patch every evening. Now weeds had started pushing up through the rows. It was getting overgrown. No one was coming down to tend it. Christos is in jail, awaiting trial. For a long time, his boots stayed outside his door. His family are still here. In the garage, his car has gathered dust.
我从叙利亚回家后，仍然试图理解关于克里斯托斯的消息。我走到他曾经每天晚上小心翼翼地给菜地浇水的花园。现在杂草已经开始从垄沟中冒出来。它开始长满杂草了。没人再下来打理了。克里斯托斯在监狱里，等待审判。很长一段时间，他的靴子都放在门外。他的家人还在那里。在车库里，他的车上落满了灰尘。
So I want to ask this. What was exciting, when you were psychotic, about the feeling of somebody spying on me or there are spies out there?
所以我想问这个。当你精神错乱时，有人监视我或者外面有间谍这种感觉有什么令人兴奋的？
It's like a validation. You go through your life unnoticed, and you want someone to pay attention to you. And the idea that someone's watching you appeals to your ego that there's some higher power that cares about you, whether it's God or an intelligence agency.
这就像一种验证。你的一生都在不被注意中度过，你希望有人能关注你。有人在监视你的想法迎合了你的自我，即有一种更高的权力在关心你，无论是上帝还是情报机构。
And how do you feel about somebody that actually is a spy? Do you like him? Do you admire him? Do you dislike him?
你对一个真正是间谍的人有什么感觉？你喜欢他吗？你钦佩他吗？你讨厌他吗？
Well, you're a spy, right?
嗯，你是间谍，对吧？
I'm a spy.
我是间谍。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Part-time job.
兼职工作。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
No, I don't think I admire them or that it's something I want to do. And also, I'd be terrified, having this secret from you. [LAUGHS] You would definitely find out if I was a spy.
不，我不认为我钦佩他们，也不认为这是我想做的事情。而且，如果我有这个秘密瞒着你，我会感到非常恐惧。[笑]如果你是间谍，你肯定会被发现的。
There really are spies, but they're not after me. They're just people living quiet, dangerous lives I'll never fully understand. I'm OK with leaving the secret missions to them.
外面确实有间谍，但他们不是冲着我来的。他们只是过着安静、危险的生活，我永远无法完全理解。我愿意把秘密任务留给他们。
Ayman Oghanna is a reporter in Greece.
艾曼·奥甘纳是希腊的一名记者。
Act Two, No Power To The People. Our show today is about people who feel like they're trapped in some situation they have no control over, like passengers on a runaway bus. And we turn next to a place where there are actually not a lot of buses running right now because the country is out of oil. It's from writer Eileen Sosin Martinez, who lives in Havana. Because it's hard to even make phone calls from there, we got an actor to read it.
第二幕，不给民众电力。我们今天的节目是关于那些感觉自己被困在某种无法控制的情况下的人们，比如失控巴士上的乘客。接下来我们要转向一个目前没有多少巴士在运行的地方，因为这个国家没有石油了。这是住在哈瓦那的作家艾琳·索辛·马丁内斯（Eileen Sosin Martinez）写的。因为在那里甚至很难打电话，我们找了一位演员来读。
About two weeks ago, I had a silly accident. I took a step backwards, thinking the sidewalk was there, but ended up stepping onto thin air. My left knee, which underwent surgery many years ago, couldn't hold me up, and I suffered a sprain. The doctor told me to take anti-inflammatories for 10 days and apply ice every two hours. I got naproxen pills on the black market, as is usually the case, given the shortage plaguing state-run pharmacies. Finding the pills was supposed to be the hard part.
大约两周前，我发生了一个愚蠢的意外。我以为人行道在那儿，向后退了一步，结果踩空了。我多年前做过手术的左膝盖支撑不住，扭伤了。医生让我服用10天消炎药，每两小时冷敷一次。我像往常一样在黑市买了萘普生药片，因为国家经营的药店一直缺货。找到药片本应是困难的部分。
Though obvious looking back, it didn't occur to me that the other part of my treatment, icing my knee every two hours, would be even harder to carry out. I filled up a half-liter bottle with water and put it in the freezer. Easy, right? Yes, if you have power. The power company used to publish a weekly blackout schedule. They'd never fully stick to it, but you'd at least get an idea of whether they would cut the power in the morning or afternoon. And usually, it would be out for no more than four hours.
虽然现在回想起来很明显，但我没料到治疗的另一部分，每两小时冷敷一次膝盖，会更难执行。我往半升的瓶子里装了水，放进冰箱。很容易，对吧？是的，如果你有电的话。电力公司过去常发布每周的停电时间表。他们从不完全遵守，但你至少能知道他们是会在早上还是下午停电。通常，停电时间不会超过四个小时。
But at the end of 2025, the blackouts started increasing. Then, in January, the United States launched an oil embargo, threatening tariffs on any country supplying Cuba with oil. In the spring, the situation changed again for the worse. The oil we got from a Russian tanker at the end of March ran out in early May. I expected an uptick in blackouts, but I never thought it would be this bad.
但在2025年底，停电开始增加。然后，在1月，美国实施了石油禁运，威胁要对任何向古巴供应石油的国家征收关税。春天，情况再次恶化。我们在3月底从一艘俄罗斯油轮上得到的石油在5月初就用完了。我预料停电会增加，但我从没想过会这么严重。
Now we don't talk about blackouts. We talk about whiteouts, [SPANISH], as they would say in the so-called "special period" of the '90s, the crisis that devastated Cuba following the collapse of the Soviet Union. In other words, instead of counting how many hours a day the power is cut, we count how long it's back on. Blackouts are the rule and power the exception.
现在我们不谈停电了。我们谈论“白电”，[西班牙语]，就像他们在那所谓的90年代“特殊时期”——苏联解体后摧毁古巴的危机——中所说的那样。换句话说，与其计算一天停电多少小时，我们计算的是电力恢复了多长时间。停电是常态，电力才是例外。
These whiteouts had been happening for at least a year in other provinces, but not in Havana. Now, not even favoritism can shield the capital from them. We are barely getting three hours of electricity a day, five at most. So, of course, there wasn't enough time for the ice I was supposed to be using on my knee to fully set. Instead of ice, I've been using cold water, a sort of slush. I alternate where I place the bottle-- on the underside of my knee, on the outside, on top, on bottom. I'm supposed to do this for 20 minutes.
这些白电在其他省份已经持续了至少一年，但在哈瓦那没有。现在，连优待都无法让首都免受其害。我们一天几乎只有三个小时的电力，最多五个小时。所以，当然，没有足够的时间让本该用于膝盖的冰块完全结冰。与其说是冰，我一直在用冷水，一种冰泥。我轮流放置瓶子的位置——在膝盖下方、外部、顶部、底部。我本该这样坚持20分钟。
If I had ice, it would ease the pain almost immediately. Cold water just cools off the skin. Still, I keep a bottle in the freezer, hoping. I remember how I'd react when the blackouts first got worse at the end of last year. When the power went out, I'd be overcome with an urge to do something, anything. It was winter, and it would already be dark at 6:00 PM. So I would exercise in the dark, read by flashlight, and wash some of my clothes by hand.
如果我有冰，它几乎能立即缓解疼痛。冷水只会冷却皮肤。尽管如此，我还是在冰箱里放了一个瓶子，怀着希望。我记得当去年年底停电加剧时我的反应。停电时，我会被一种冲动淹没，想做点什么，任何事。那是冬天，晚上6点天就黑了。所以我会在黑暗中锻炼，借着手电筒看书，手工洗一些衣服。
Now it's flipped. When the electricity goes out, I feel drained, helpless. But I feel euphoric when the power's back on. Are you happy, my love? My boyfriend asked me on one of these occasions. It was only then that I realized I was singing while dicing onions for dinner. When the electricity is back on, people run to their washing machines, hoping the power lasts enough to get the laundry done. That's also the only chance to use the blender to have juice for breakfast or to make puree for a baby.
现在反过来了。当电力中断时，我感到被抽干、无助。但电力恢复时，我感到欣快。你高兴吗，亲爱的？我男朋友在这些时候问我。只有那时我才意识到我在为晚餐切洋葱时在唱歌。当电力恢复时，人们冲向洗衣机，希望电力能持续足够长的时间来完成洗衣。这也是使用搅拌机制作早餐果汁或为婴儿制作果泥的唯一机会。
I'm lucky. I have a gas stove, but many rely on electricity to cook. They use those precious hours to turn on rice and multicookers so there'll be food for the next day. Then everyone, rich and poor alike, faces the same problem-- how to preserve food. You need a whole system and a great memory.
我很幸运。我有煤气灶，但许多人依靠电力做饭。他们利用那宝贵的几个小时打开电饭煲和多功能锅，这样第二天就有食物了。然后每个人，无论贫富，都面临着同样的问题——如何保存食物。你需要一套完整的系统和极好的记忆力。
The first rule is, don't cook what you planned. Cook what's defrosting the fastest. For example, if you open a can of tomato sauce or corn, you have to store it again in a plastic container and put it in the freezer. The lower part of the fridge barely works and is now basically a cupboard. Cooked rice, cooked pasta, it all goes in the freezer. I've had to throw out so much food because of lack of refrigeration-- carrots, chicken, mangoes, yucca, way too much rice. Throwing out food in the middle of food shortages feels like sacrilege.
第一条规则是，不要做你计划做的饭。做融化最快的。例如，如果你打开一罐番茄酱或玉米，你必须把它重新存放在塑料容器里放进冰箱。冰箱下半部分几乎不工作，现在基本上是个橱柜。煮熟的米饭、煮熟的意大利面，全都放进冷冻室。因为缺乏冷藏，我不得不扔掉太多食物——胡萝卜、鸡肉、芒果、木薯，还有太多的米饭。在食品短缺的情况下扔掉食物感觉像是亵渎。
And while we're all going slowly mad waiting for a small cube of ice to form in the freezer, there are other indignities-- for example, the trash, which piles up on street corners like monuments to this disaster. This also isn't a new problem. For the past few years, garbage collection has varied throughout cities and neighborhoods. Maybe the truck went by yesterday in some places and weeks or months ago in others. But now, it's much worse.
当我们都在等待冰箱里结出一小块冰而慢慢变疯时，还有其他的屈辱——例如，堆在街角的垃圾，就像这场灾难的纪念碑。这也不是什么新问题。过去几年，不同城市和社区的垃圾收集情况各不相同。也许有些地方卡车昨天刚经过，而有些地方是几周或几个月前。但现在，情况更糟了。
According to officials, there's no gas for garbage trucks, which, to top things off, break down with no replacement parts available. Clinging to a shred of civic responsibility, we take out our household trash and walk for a few blocks until we find bins that aren't overflowing, leaving it where it's least obstructive.
据官员称，垃圾车没油了，而且雪上加霜的是，它们坏了，又没有替换零件。为了保留一丝公民责任感，我们把家庭垃圾拿出来，走几个街区找到没满的垃圾桶，把垃圾留在最不碍事的地方。
Just a few yards from my door, you'll find one of those garbage piles, haloed by innumerable flies that have also made their way into my home. They're always riled up early in the morning, touching your arm and back and buzzing in your face while you're making coffee. I'll brush them off and shoo them away, but they come back. It doesn't matter that everything's clean. They're already inside. And you can't take your eyes off your mug or the bread you got for breakfast, because they'll land on them the minute you do.
离我家门口几码远的地方，你就能找到一堆这样的垃圾，周围环绕着无数的苍蝇，它们也飞进了我的家里。它们清晨总是很亢奋，在倒咖啡时碰你的手臂和背部，在你的脸上嗡嗡作响。我会把它们赶走，但它们又回来了。一切都很干净也没用。它们已经在里面了。你不能把眼睛从杯子或早餐吃的面包上移开，因为你一离开，它们就会落上去。
A few days ago, I heard a neighbor complain about the heat, but she would rather shut all her doors and windows than let in flies. Sometimes I'll also leave my windows closed to keep out the stench of garbage. I'll peek out onto the street and see flies in the flower garden landing on tall grass, bending over under their weight, as if it were a wheat stalk made up of insects instead of grains.
几天前，我听到一个邻居抱怨天气热，但她宁愿关上所有的门窗也不愿让苍蝇进来。有时我也把窗户关着以隔绝垃圾的恶臭。我会窥视街道，看到花坛里的苍蝇落在高高的草丛上，在它们的重量下弯下腰，就像那是一根由昆虫而不是谷物组成的麦秆。
People started setting these piles of garbage on fire, and there was smoke everywhere. So much garbage is still there, and the temperature's rising. I wouldn't be surprised if one day, there's a spontaneous combustion. That's a real thing that can happen. A few days ago, the garbage pile near my house caught fire. We heard a little explosion, and when I looked out the window, it had already started burning.
人们开始放火烧这些垃圾堆，到处都是烟。这么多垃圾还在那里，气温正在升高。如果有一天，这里发生自燃，我一点也不会感到惊讶。那确实是可能发生的事情。几天前，我家附近的垃圾堆着火了。我们听到一声小爆炸，当我看向窗外时，它已经开始燃烧了。
I called the firefighters at 5:00 PM. It was very windy, and the smoke cloud was spreading. A while went by, and since the firemen hadn't come, my boyfriend and I took advantage of the fact that the flames had died down a bit and doused them with buckets of water. We thought we'd put them out, but that wasn't the case. I kept calling the emergency line. The firefighters finally arrived at 8:00 PM. Our house smelled like smoke for days.
我在下午5点给消防员打了电话。风很大，烟云在蔓延。过了一会儿，由于消防员没来，我和我男朋友利用火焰已经减弱了一点的机会，用桶装水浇灭了它们。我们以为扑灭了，但事实并非如此。我一直打紧急求助电话。消防员终于在晚上8点赶到了。我们家好几天都弥漫着烟味。
I don't know what's more disturbing, the growing number of sleepless nights or the torture of not knowing how much longer this will last. I still haven't found an answer to the latter. To try and solve the former, the restless nights, we bought a rechargeable fan-- $40 for a tiny plastic fan. My fan pretty much looks like a toy, but now I no longer wake up sweating in the middle of the night.
我不知道哪种更让人不安，是越来越多的不眠之夜，还是不知道还要持续多久的折磨。关于后者，我还没找到答案。为了解决前者，即不安的夜晚，我们买了一个可充电风扇——40美元买了一个微小的塑料风扇。我的风扇看起来几乎像个玩具，但现在我半夜不会再满头大汗地醒来了。
The sound of the spinning blades has become a sort of lullaby that helps me fall asleep, like so many people on this sweltering island, because on blackout nights, sometimes the silence is more frightening than the darkness. I live at the end of an avenue where you used to hear loud conversations, music, and cars well past midnight. Now, the streets are empty.
旋转扇叶的声音已经变成了一种催眠曲，帮助我入睡，就像这个闷热岛上的许多人一样，因为在停电的夜晚，有时沉默比黑暗更令人恐惧。我住在大道尽头，那里过去在午夜过后还能听到大声的谈话、音乐和汽车声。现在，街道空空如也。
I don't exactly sleep like a baby. If the power comes back at 2:00 or 4:00 in the morning, I have to leap out of bed and charge everything-- power banks, the lamp, the laptop. And if they shut it off before morning, I have to get up again and turn the rechargeable fan back on. Lately, whenever my mom or aunts message me on WhatsApp to ask me how I'm doing, I almost always answer, "I'm here, in a blackout," as if I too only ran on electricity, as if the darkness and silence were a part of me.
我并没有像婴儿一样安睡。如果电力在凌晨2点或4点恢复，我得跳下床给所有东西充电——充电宝、台灯、笔记本电脑。如果天亮前他们关掉电源，我得再次起床，重新打开可充电风扇。最近，每当我妈妈或阿姨在WhatsApp上问我好不好时，我几乎总是回答，“我在这儿，停电了，”好像我也是只靠电运行的一样，好像黑暗和沉默成了我的一部分。
A few nights ago, a bunch of neighbors started banging on pots and pans. I've seen countless videos on social media of these cacerolazos. But I'd never had it happen so close, on my own block. Honestly, it sounded more like a raging party than public outcry. You could hear voices yelling, vamos! And bang them, bang them! It felt like a kind of release, like their weariness had reached its limit. And at the same time, there was a sense of fun, of mischief. Aside from two or three notable occasions, there hasn't been a massive protest in Cuba in decades. But now we have these cacerolazos.
几天前，一群邻居开始敲打锅碗瓢盆。我在社交媒体上看过无数这些“抗议敲打”的视频。但我从来没有在如此近距离、就在我自己的街区发生过。老实说，这听起来更像是一场疯狂的派对，而不是公众抗议。你能听到人们大喊，“加油！”和“敲吧，敲吧！”这感觉像是一种释放，仿佛他们的疲惫已经到了极限。同时，有一种乐趣和恶作剧的感觉。除了两三次著名的场合，古巴几十年来没有发生过大规模抗议。但现在我们有了这些抗议。
After about 15 minutes of outrage, the power came back on. It was probably just a coincidence, but it felt wonderful to hear shouts of joy, as if the protests had really worked. And then a few minutes after that, the power shut back off. Nobody yelled or made any noise.
在经过大约15分钟的愤怒后，电力恢复了。这可能只是个巧合，但听到欢呼声感觉棒极了，仿佛抗议真的奏效了。然后几分钟后，电力又断了。没人再大喊大叫或发出任何声音。
A few days later, they turned the power back on at night, and it lasted until 6:00 in the morning. These were seven hours where the fridge door was barely opened, which meant that the next morning, my half-liter water bottle had completely frozen. 10 days after getting my doctor's orders, I was finally able to ice my left knee.
几天后，他们晚上恢复了供电，一直持续到早上6点。这七个小时里，冰箱门几乎没打开过，这意味着第二天早上，我的半升水瓶已经完全结冰了。在得到医生医嘱10天后，我终于可以冷敷我的左膝盖了。
Actor Ana Villafane reading a story by Eileen Sosin Martinez, whose reporting you can find in The Guardian and elsewhere. Ana is currently starring in Sinatra on London's West End. Gabriela Munoz Ravello translated Eileen's story from Spanish to English. Coming up, if a tree falls in a forest, could it ever possibly be murder? A crime that captivated England goes before a High Court judge. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
演员安娜·维拉法恩读的是艾琳·索辛·马丁内斯的故事，她的报道可以在《卫报》和其他地方找到。安娜目前正在伦敦西区出演《弗兰克·辛纳屈》。加布里埃拉·穆尼奥斯·拉韦洛将艾琳的故事从西班牙语翻译成了英语。接下来，如果森林里的一棵树倒下，这有可能被认为是谋杀吗？一个迷住了英国的犯罪案件提交给了高等法院法官。节目将在芝加哥公共广播电台的一分钟后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm David Kestenbaum. This week's show, Trapped on a Bus, people stuck in situations they cannot control and do not like. We are at Act Three. Act Three, Murder, Tree Wrote. Sometimes an entire country can be taken on an unexpected journey against its will. That happened in England recently. And I'm not talking about their inability to keep a prime minister. I'm talking about a crime so confounding, so nonsensical, people just could not wrap their heads around it. Rosa Lyster tells the story.
这是《美国生活》。我是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。本周的节目，《被困在巴士上》，关于那些陷入自己无法控制且不喜欢的情况的人们。我们进入了第三幕。第三幕，谋杀，树写的。有时，整个国家都会违背其意愿踏上一场意想不到的旅程。这最近在英国发生了。我指的不是他们无法留住首相的能力。我指的是一起如此令人困惑、如此荒谬的犯罪，人们根本无法理解。罗莎·利斯特（Rosa Lyster）讲述了这个故事。
In September 2023, a farmer called the Northumberland National Park to report a fallen tree, not just any tree-- a sycamore, more than 100 years old, by some reports, the most photographed tree in Britain. It stood in the depression between two hills in the desolate landscape of the park in a gap in a stone wall. Not just any stone wall-- an especially picturesque section of Hadrian's Wall, which was built by the Romans across the narrowest part of England. Photographers went crazy for the tree.
2023年9月，一位农民致电诺森伯兰国家公园报告一棵倒下的树，不仅是一棵普通的树——一棵无花果树，有100多年历史，据报道是英国被拍照最多的树。它矗立在公园荒凉景观中两座小山之间的洼地，在一个石墙的缺口处。不仅是一道普通的石墙——它是哈德良长城一个特别风景优美的部分，长城是罗马人在英国最狭窄处建造的。摄影师们为这棵树而疯狂。
The park ranger who arrived at the scene assumed at first that it had been blown down by the high winds the night before, until he saw the cleanness of the cut. He told the BBC, "Once you realize it's been chopped down, then it's going to become a massive worldwide story." I'd never heard of the tree before it got cut down, and neither had anyone I knew. I live in London, though. The tree was a beloved landmark of England's North East, its silhouette instantly recognizable to those who knew it. And, as virtually every news report would go on to stress, it had also been featured in the 1991 movie, Robin Hood, Prince of Thieves.
赶到现场的公园管理员起初认为它是被前一天晚上的大风吹倒的，直到他看到了那整齐的切口。他告诉BBC，“一旦你意识到它是被砍倒的，那么它就会成为一个巨大的全球故事。”在这棵树被砍掉之前，我从未听说过它，我认识的人也都没有听说过。不过，我住在伦敦。这棵树是英国东北部备受喜爱的地标，对于那些了解它的人来说，它的轮廓瞬间就能辨认出来。而且，正如几乎每一篇新闻报道随后都会强调的那样，它还出现在1991年的电影《侠盗罗宾汉》中。
Even so, I was surprised to see that quite quickly, the lamentation went beyond those with a personal link to the tree. People across the country began to speak of the death of the tree, calling it slaughter and comparing its loss to that of a close family member or to the death of Princess Diana. They said they felt as if their hearts had been ripped out. They spoke of evil and desecration and named the fantastical medieval-seeming punishments that they would like to see visited on the scumbags who could have done this.
即便如此，我很惊讶地发现，哀悼很快就超越了那些与这棵树有个人联系的人。全国各地的人们开始谈论这棵树的死亡，称其为屠杀，并将它的损失比作失去亲密的家庭成员或戴安娜王妃的去世。他们说他们感觉好像他们的心被掏空了。他们谈到了邪恶和亵渎，并说出了他们希望看到那些能做出这种事的混蛋们受到什么样的奇幻中世纪式的惩罚。
Steve Blair, the manager of a nearby pub, told me about the day he truly understood that it was gone. It was the first snowfall, he said. You'd get people taking photographs of the tree because it's covered in snow and it looks so, so, so good. I was driving to work, and as I came over the hill, you would normally see the photographers all over Sycamore Gap. And then, on this specific day, there was no one there anymore.
附近一家酒吧的经理史蒂夫·布莱尔告诉我，他真正理解这棵树消失的那一天。他说，那是第一场降雪。你会看到人们给这棵树拍照，因为它覆盖着雪，看起来非常非常非常棒。我正开车去上班，当我翻过山丘时，你通常会看到摄影师们遍布在无花果树缝（Sycamore Gap）。然后，在这一天，那里已经没有人了。
For about a month, nobody had any idea who had felled the tree. Then, acting on a tip, the Northumbria police brought in two local men, a mechanic named Adam Carruthers and his friend, a tree surgeon named Daniel Graham. Six months later, the two men appeared at Newcastle Magistrates' Court. They walked in together, a united front, wearing balaclavas to avoid the cameras outside the courthouse.
大约一个月的时间里，没有人知道是谁砍倒了那棵树。后来，根据线报，诺森布里亚警方带走了两名当地男子，一名名叫亚当·卡鲁瑟斯（Adam Carruthers）的机械师和他的朋友，一名名叫丹尼尔·格雷厄姆（Daniel Graham）的树艺师。六个月后，两人出现在纽卡斯尔地方法院。他们一起走进法院，形成统一战线，戴着巴拉克拉法帽以避开法院外的摄像机。
The two men were charged with criminal damage amounting to 623,335 pounds, over 800,000 American dollars. According to prosecutors, this extraordinarily specific figure was arrived at, in part, using something called the Capital Asset Value for Amenity Trees system, a method local governments use to calculate the worth of trees. Graham pleaded not guilty, while Carruthers entered no plea.
两人被指控犯有刑事损害罪，涉及金额623,335英镑，超过80万美元。据检方称，这个极其具体的数字是在一定程度上通过使用所谓的“资本资产价值景观树系统”得出的，这是地方政府用于计算树木价值的一种方法。格雷厄姆拒不认罪，而卡鲁瑟斯未作答辩。
In the intense media coverage that followed, reporters and commentators struggled to come up with plausible reasons why the two men-- or, indeed, anyone on Earth-- would have felled the tree. Some sort of ancient act of revenge, or a grievance against the local government, possibly? Was it a protest, perhaps, driven by very left-wing ideas, or else, very right-wing ones? A case could be made for either. The explanation, whatever the hell it might be, would surely emerge at trial.
在随后的强烈媒体报道中，记者和评论员们努力想出两名男子——或者地球上任何人——砍倒这棵树的合理理由。某种古代的复仇行为，或者对地方政府的不满吗？这可能是一次抗议吗，也许是出于极左思想，或者是极右思想？这两种说法都有理由成立。无论到底是什么解释，肯定会在审判中浮出水面。
The Sycamore Gap trial began in late April of last year. There was Carruthers, the young family man, dressed in a shiny black suit that was too big for him, blinking and swallowing and staring hard into the middle distance. And there was Graham, gaunt and guarded and fizzing with tension. He was only a few years older than Carruthers but looked old enough to be his dad.
无花果树缝审判于去年4月底开始。那是卡鲁瑟斯，那个年轻的顾家男人，穿着一套对他来说太大的亮黑色西装，眨眼、吞咽，并努力凝视着前方。还有格雷厄姆，枯瘦、警惕，充满紧张感。他只比卡鲁瑟斯大几岁，但看起来老得足以当他爸爸了。
A senior High Court judge, Justice Christina Lambert, had been appointed. High Court judges deal with the most serious and complicated trials in England and Wales. Many of Lambert's recent cases have involved grave crimes of the sort that society considers unthinkable. In 2024, she was one of three senior judges appointed to consider the appeal of Lucy Letby, the nurse convicted of the murder of seven babies. Even at the start of the trial, there was talk of a prison sentence if the two men were found guilty.
一位高级高等法院法官，克里斯蒂娜·兰伯特法官（Justice Christina Lambert），已被任命。高等法院法官处理英格兰和威尔士最严重和复杂的审判。兰伯特的许多近期案件都涉及社会认为不可想象的严重犯罪。2024年，她是三位被任命考虑露西·莱比（Lucy Letby）上诉的高级法官之一，这名护士被判谋杀七名婴儿。甚至在审判开始时，就有传言说如果两人被判有罪，他们将面临监禁。
The atmosphere in the courtroom was notably strange, both entirely serious and entirely ridiculous. On the press bench, reporters murmured to one another that it felt a bit like a murder trial. It didn't, though, not exactly. Nobody was dead. There were no grieving family members. I couldn't seem to keep a handle on what was at stake, what law the two men had actually broken. Between sessions, I kept having to look up the legal definition of murder to check one more time whether the term could be applied to anything other than the killing of a human being. It cannot.
法庭内的气氛特别奇怪，既极其严肃又极其荒谬。在记者席上，记者们低声交谈，觉得这有点像谋杀审判。不过，并非完全如此，并不完全是。没有人死亡。没有悲痛的家庭成员。我似乎无法掌握赌注是什么，这两人究竟触犯了什么法律。在庭审期间，我不得不反复查阅谋杀的法律定义，再次核实这个术语是否可以应用于除杀害人类以外的任何事物。事实是不能。
At other times, people in the public gallery would burst into laughter, to Judge Lambert's immense and theatrical disapproval. She had a way of peering over her spectacles. Officially, the jury was being presented with a straightforward question of criminal damage. Were Adam Carruthers and Daniel Graham responsible for cutting down a sycamore by Hadrian's Wall on the night of September 27, 2023? Unfortunately for the defendants, this turned out to be exceptionally easy to answer.
在其他时候，公众席上的人会爆发笑声，这引起了兰伯特法官极大的、戏剧性的不满。她有一种从眼镜上方窥视的方式。正式来说，陪审团被提交了一个直接的刑事损害问题。亚当·卡鲁瑟斯和丹尼尔·格雷厄姆是否对2023年9月27日晚砍倒哈德良长城边的一棵无花果树负责？不幸的是，对于被告来说，这个问题答案出奇地容易。
To begin with, there was CCTV footage of the Range Rover driving to and from the parking lot near the tree. Graham's phone was tracked traveling to and from the site. On the same phone, the police recovered a nearly three-minute video, very dimly lit, of a small figure working at the trunk of a large tree, a chainsaw droning in the background, leaning his whole weight into the job until the crackling collapse began. They also recovered a photo of a tree wedge and a chainsaw in Graham's trunk.
首先，有路虎行驶到树附近的停车场的闭路电视录像。格雷厄姆的手机被追踪到往返于该地点。在同一部手机上，警方恢复了一段近三分钟的视频，光线非常暗，显示一个小身影在砍伐一棵大树的树干，背景是电锯的嗡嗡声，他把全身的重量都压在工作上，直到坍塌开始。他们还恢复了一张格雷厄姆后备箱里放着树楔和电锯的照片。
The two men had sent each other voice notes, talking about the heaviness of the chainsaw and the amount of coverage that the crime was getting. In one of them, Graham seemed as if he would combust with elation, letting Carruthers know that the tree was "on fucking Sky News as we speak." What else? There was a selfie Graham had taken, in which he is squinting into the camera, looking pleased, while in the background, Carruthers once again saws away with evident expertise at the trunk of a large tree.
两人互相发送了语音笔记，讨论电锯的重量以及这起犯罪所获得的关注度。在其中一条中，格雷厄姆似乎兴奋得要爆炸，告诉卡鲁瑟斯，这棵树“现在就在该死的天空新闻（Sky News）上”。还有什么？有一张格雷厄姆自拍的照片，照片中他眯着眼睛看着镜头，看起来很满意，而背景中，卡鲁瑟斯再次熟练地锯着一棵大树的树干。
Neither of the men held up well under questioning. It's strange to see people tell such brazen and low-effort lies in front of the international media and a High Court judge. Carruthers, the younger man, was by far the more amiable of the two, striving to seem tractable and reasonable while nevertheless lying flamboyantly. His approach throughout the trial was to state over and over that he had no idea who could have done it, none at all. He brought up his partner, Amy, and their two young children often. Carruthers seemed basically ordinary. He looked scared.
两人在盘问下都没有坚持多久。看到人们在国际媒体和高等法院法官面前撒下如此无耻且低水平的谎言，真是奇怪。卡鲁瑟斯，那个年轻人，是两人中比较和蔼的一个，努力显得随和且讲理，但同时又在浮夸地撒谎。他在整个审判中的做法是一遍又一遍地声称他不知道是谁干的，完全不知道。他经常提到他的伴侣艾米和他们的两个小孩。卡鲁瑟斯看起来基本上很普通。他看起来很害怕。
Graham was different, a character from another moral universe altogether. I don't know if I've ever seen a person radiate scorn more thoroughly than he did. He seemed contemptuous of everything-- trees, other people, the concept of truth. He made a point of mentioning how alone he was in the world and how fine he was with this state of affairs. The press box is directly behind the witness stand, so I couldn't see his face as he spoke. But he still managed to make the back of his skinny, tattooed neck convey the suggestion that we all go and fuck ourselves.
格雷厄姆则不同，他完全是另一个道德世界的人物。我不知道我是否见过有人比他更彻底地散发出蔑视。他似乎蔑视一切——树木、其他人、真理的概念。他特意提到他在世界上是多么孤独，以及他对这种状态是多么满意。媒体席就在证人席后面，所以我看不到他说话时的表情。但他仍然设法让那瘦削、有纹身的脖子后面传达出一种让我们所有人都去死的意思。
He lied beyond the point of sense or even reason, conceding that, yes, that was his car at the site, and yes, the video of the tree being sawed down was on his phone, but that none of this proved a thing. He said he left his keys in his car for the use of anyone who happened to be passing by. Carruthers could have taken it. In a police interview, Graham had provided other possibilities-- a stranger from nearby Carlisle or his stepdaughter's boyfriend. As far as I'm aware, he doesn't have a stepdaughter. He said he had "no interest" in sycamores-- "I cut trees down. I don't collect them."
他撒谎到了超越感官甚至理性的程度，承认是的，那是他的车在现场，是的，锯倒树的视频在他的手机里，但这些什么也证明不了。他说他把钥匙留在车里供任何碰巧路过的人使用。卡鲁瑟斯可能拿走了它。在警察采访中，格雷厄姆提供了其他可能性——来自附近卡莱尔的陌生人或者他继女的男朋友。据我所知，他没有继女。他说他对无花果树“没兴趣”——“我砍树，我不收藏它们。”
Not everything Graham said came across as a fabrication that could be dismantled on the spot. He appeared sincere, for instance, when talking about his father's suicide and about how he and Carruthers had become friends. Carruthers had helped him fix his father's Land Rover in time for the funeral. He also didn't seem to be lying, exactly, when it came to the matter of the string.
并非格雷厄姆说的每一件事看起来都是可以当场拆穿的捏造。例如，当谈到他父亲的自杀，以及他和卡鲁瑟斯是如何成为朋友时，他显得很真诚。卡鲁瑟斯曾帮他修好了他父亲的陆虎车，赶上了葬礼。在绳子的问题上，他似乎也没有撒谎。
Under questioning, he explained that he had first heard of the sycamore sometime in 2021, when he had gone into Carruthers's workshop and asked if he could borrow a piece of string. Carruthers refused, saying that the string had great sentimental meaning for him. Then, according to Graham, Carruthers laid the string in a circle on the floor of his workshop. He told Graham that the circumference of the circle exactly matched the trunk of the most famous tree in the world.
在盘问下，他解释说他第一次听说这棵无花果树是在2021年的某个时候，当时他走进卡鲁瑟斯的车间，问能否借一根绳子。卡鲁瑟斯拒绝了，说这根绳子对他有重大的情感意义。然后，根据格雷厄姆的说法，卡鲁瑟斯把绳子在车间地板上摆成一个圆圈。他告诉格雷厄姆，圆圈的周长正好匹配世界上最著名树木的树干。
Nobody could quite work out what to do with this story. Lawyers for both sides kept bringing it up, but no one seemed clear on how the information ought to be used. It was too weird a detail to be helpful in a courtroom, but it was also too weird to ignore, because it didn't seem like something that a person would just invent. If he'd simply wanted to account for how he had learned of the tree's existence, Graham could have said almost anything, instead of this otherworldly business about a piece of string that contains within it the essence of a beloved tree, like something out of the Brothers Grimm. In fact, the whole thing seemed like a fairytale that had made its way into a courtroom.
没人能完全弄清楚怎么处理这个故事。双方的律师不断提出它，但没有人清楚应该如何利用这些信息。这是一个太奇怪的细节，在法庭上帮不上忙，但也太奇怪了，不能被忽略，因为它看起来不像是一个人会凭空捏造的事情。如果他只是想解释他是如何得知这棵树存在的，格雷厄姆几乎可以编造任何东西，而不是这个关于绳子的超自然故事，绳子里面包含了一棵被珍爱树木的精髓，就像格林童话里的东西。事实上，整件事看起来像是一个走进法庭的童话。
It often felt as if the most important question in the courtroom was not whether Carruthers and Graham had done it, but whether they-- or anyone-- understood what it was that they had done. There was a kind of collective effort to affirm that something terrible had happened, something much worse than ordinary criminal damage, much worse than simply cutting down a tree. How else to account for the ferocity of the public indignation? At one point, Carruthers said that he hadn't been able to understand what all the fuss was about. My understanding, he said, was that it was just a tree.
经常感觉法庭上最重要的不是卡鲁瑟斯和格雷厄姆是否做了这件事，而是他们——或者任何人——是否理解他们所做的事。有一种集体的努力来确认发生了什么可怕的事情，比普通的刑事损害严重得多，比仅仅砍倒一棵树严重得多。否则如何解释公众愤怒的猛烈程度？有一次，卡鲁瑟斯说他无法理解大惊小怪什么。他说，我的理解是，它只是一棵树。
The truth is that people in Britain don't really like sycamores. Gardeners go so far as to despise them. They are among the only trees in the country that are regularly referred to as weeds. They are prolific self-seeders. One mature tree can be the parent of thousands of seedlings in a single year. They can grow almost anywhere. And they do. They are non-native, which some people have strong feelings about. The sycamore's tendency to flourish in places where plenty of other trees would wither and die might have been the reason that John Clayton, a 19th-century landowner, planted one in a gap along Hadrian's Wall.
事实是，英国人并不真正喜欢无花果树。园丁甚至鄙视它们。它们是国内为数不多经常被称为杂草的树木之一。它们是多产的自播种树。一棵成熟的树一年内可以是成千上万幼苗的母体。它们几乎可以在任何地方生长。而且它们确实如此。它们是非本地的，有些人对此有强烈的情感。无花果树在许多其他树木会枯萎和死亡的地方蓬勃发展的趋势，可能是19世纪的土地所有者约翰·克莱顿在哈德良长城的一个缺口处种下一棵的原因。
The wall, whose construction began in the year 122, was built to mark the northwestern boundary of the Roman Empire, serving as a frontier, customs post, and reminder of the reach of power. Clayton planted the sycamore presumably because he thought it would look nice there, an isolated tree right in the middle of a dramatic dip in the landscape, the wall running steeply up each side of it, such that hikers could look down on it as they approached.
这道墙建于公元122年，是为了标志罗马帝国的西北边界，兼作边境、海关哨所和权力的象征。克莱顿种下这棵无花果树大概是因为他认为它在那里看起来会很不错，一棵孤立的树正好处于风景中一个戏剧性的洼地，城墙陡峭地顺着两边向上，这样徒步旅行者在靠近时可以俯瞰它。
Carruthers and Graham were sentenced in July. Before the sentencing, a junior counsel presented a victim impact statement. This consisted of emails and messages from members of the public, read in a loud, slow, tragic voice. She tried her best. They said things like, "I've never felt this way about any other tree," and "This feels like losing a close family member," and "RIP BEAUTIFUL TREE I WISH I'D GOT TO MEET YOU."
卡鲁瑟斯和格雷厄姆在7月被判刑。在判刑之前，一名初级律师提交了一份受害者影响声明。这由来自公众的电子邮件和信息组成，以响亮、缓慢、悲剧性的语调朗读。她尽了最大努力。他们说的话如，“我从未对任何其他树有这种感觉，”以及，“这感觉像是失去了亲密的家庭成员，”以及，“安息吧美丽的树，我真希望我能见到你。”
Carruthers and Graham were each given four years and three months in prison. The sentence seemed weirdly over the top. When people cut down a tree in England, what usually happens is nothing-- that, or a fine. The sentence, Judge Lambert said, was based on a consideration of "the social impact of the offense." People had loved the tree, she said, and Carruthers and Graham had destroyed it in an act of vandalism that was somehow both mindless and premeditated. According to a tree lawyer I talked to, it was the first time anyone in the United Kingdom had gone to prison for cutting down a single tree.
卡鲁瑟斯和格雷厄姆每人被判入狱四年零三个月。这个判决看起来奇怪地过重。当人们在英国砍倒一棵树时，通常发生的是什么都不做——或者罚款。兰伯特法官说，判决是基于对“犯罪社会影响”的考虑。她说，人们热爱这棵树，而卡鲁瑟斯和格雷厄姆以一种既盲目又预谋的破坏行为摧毁了它。据我采访的一位树木律师说，这是英国历史上第一次有人因为砍倒一棵树而入狱。
I only got to see the stump. I visited in late spring. It was very sunny. The remnants of the sycamore come into view as you get to the top of a slithery flight of stairs set into the bank. Then you look down at the stump, which is in precisely the spot where it would have been good to come across a tree, a nice, tall one with spreading branches, pretty old, standing totally alone in the landscape, looking like the idea of shelter.
我只看到了树桩。我在暮春时节去了那里。天气非常晴朗。当你登上建在岸边那滑溜溜的楼梯顶端时，无花果树的残余出现在视野中。然后你俯视树桩，它正好处于那种本该遇到一棵好树的地方，一棵有着伸展枝干的高大树木，相当老了，完全孤独地立在风景中，看起来像庇护所的概念。
Before this, I hadn't grasped why the locals had gotten so worked up over a single tree, let alone the rest of the country. Up close, though, their reactions made more sense. The tree had been special. And Carruthers and Graham never explained-- in a satisfying way-- why they had cut it down.
在此之前，我没明白为什么当地人会对一棵树大惊小怪，更不用说全国其他人了。然而，近距离观察时，他们的反应变得更有道理了。这棵树曾经是特别的。而卡鲁瑟斯和格雷厄姆从未以一种令人满意的方式解释——为什么他们砍倒了它。
Before their sentencing, they finally admitted they had done it. Carruthers said he was blackout drunk, and Graham said he was just keeping Carruthers company. The judge did not accept this explanation, and neither did anyone else. Whenever I talk to people about the trial, the explanation was pretty simple in their minds-- Adam Carruthers and Daniel Graham were morons. They always said that-- "morons," or else "mindless," or else "absolutely mindless and brain dead, no?"
在判刑前，他们终于承认是他们做的。卡鲁瑟斯说他喝得不省人事，格雷厄姆说他只是在陪伴卡鲁瑟斯。法官不接受这个解释，其他人也不接受。每当我与人谈论审判时，他们的心目中的解释都很简单——亚当·卡鲁瑟斯和丹尼尔·格雷厄姆是白痴。他们总是那样说——“白痴”，或者“盲目的”，或者“绝对盲目和脑死亡，不是吗？”
Almost everybody said something along these lines. They wanted to believe that Carruthers and Graham had done it because they were very stupid or not thinking at all. I could understand why. The alternative and obvious explanation-- that they had thought about it quite extensively, that they knew how much people had loved the tree and had cut it down for precisely that reason-- that's much more disturbing.
几乎每个人都说了类似的话。他们想相信卡鲁瑟斯和格雷厄姆做了这件事是因为他们非常愚蠢或者根本没动脑子。我能理解为什么。那种替代的且明显的解释——他们对此进行了相当广泛的思考，他们知道人们有多么热爱这棵树，并正是为了这个原因砍倒了它——那要令人不安得多。
Rosa Lyster lives in London. A version of this story was first published in Harper's Magazine. Will Stephenson edited that version of the story. Aviva DeKornfeld produced our radio version.
罗莎·利斯特住在伦敦。这个故事的一个版本首先发表在《哈珀杂志》上。威尔·史蒂芬森编辑了那个版本的故事。阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德制作了我们的广播版本。
Act Four, In Flight Snack. We started today's show with someone trapped on a bus, and we're going to end it with someone trapped on a plane. The someone is Leticia Lima. When she was 16, she was boarding a flight from Sao Paulo, where she lived, to Germany, when this older woman sat down next to her and did something that Leticia still thinks about to this day. Producer Tobin Low talked to her about that strange interaction, which started as soon as she got on the plane.
第四幕，飞行零食。我们今天节目开始时讲了一个被困在巴士上的人，我们要以一个被困在飞机上的人来结束它。这个人是莱蒂西亚·利马（Leticia Lima）。她16岁时，正要登上从她居住的圣保罗飞往德国的航班，这时这位年长的女士坐在了她旁边，做了一件莱蒂西亚至今仍会想起的事情。制片人托宾·洛（Tobin Low）和她谈了这次奇怪的互动，这一切从她上飞机的那一刻就开始了。
I board early. I'm sitting in my seat, which was a window seat all the way in the back of the airplane, close to the toilets in the back of the airplane. And eventually, this lady comes and sits next to me. And she immediately starts talking to me. And I thought, oh god, no. Like I've sat next to--
我提前登机。我坐在我的座位上，那是飞机的最靠后的一排靠窗座位，离机尾的厕所很近。最终，这位女士过来坐在了我旁边。她立刻开始跟我说话。我想，天哪，不。就像我曾坐在……
A nightmare.
一场噩梦。
Yeah. I've sat next to someone who wants to chat. I really don't want to chat. But my parents taught me to be polite to my elders. So I'm kind of nodding along to what she's saying and trying not to engage or show too much interest but also not be rude.
是的。我坐在一个想聊天的人旁边。我真的不想聊天。但我父母教我要对长辈有礼貌。所以我一边点着头附和她说的话，一边试图不参与或表现出太多的兴趣，但也不显得粗鲁。
Yeah. What is she saying to you when she sits down?
是的。她坐下时对你说了什么？
First, she's got this bag with her, and she's taking all these things out of her bag and looking for something. And she kept apologizing that she was looking for something. And then she pulled out this huge rosary. And she's like, OK, now I've got it. And then she starts telling me, I'm quite nervous because this is my first time on an airplane.
起初，她带着这个包，她在从包里拿出所有这些东西，寻找某种东西。她一直在为她在寻找东西而道歉。然后她掏出了这串巨大的念珠。她说，好吧，现在我找到了。然后她开始告诉我，我非常紧张，因为这是我第一次坐飞机。
Oh, no.
哦，不。
And I said, oh, OK. And she said, yeah, she was from somewhere in the countryside and had taken a bus for 18 hours or something to get to Sao Paulo to fly out. And she was flying out because her daughter had gone to Germany for work and had met a German man and was getting married, and so they had sent her the tickets to come to the wedding.
我说，哦，好吧。她说，是的，她来自乡村的某个地方，坐了18个小时的巴士之类的才到圣保罗坐飞机。她之所以要飞出去，是因为她的女儿去德国工作，遇到了一个德国男人，要结婚了，所以他们给她寄了机票来参加婚礼。
But she's going on and on. And I could tell she was quite nervous because she kept fidgeting with the rosary, and she's just talking. And then she couldn't put on her seatbelt, so I'm helping her with her seatbelt. And so she says to me at that point, can I ask you for a favor? And I said, sure. And she said, can I hold your hand? And I thought it was a bit awkward, but I said, OK, sure. So I'm sitting in the window seat. She was sitting to my left. So I gave her my left hand. And she held on really, really tight with her right hand.
但她一直在喋喋不休。我能看出她很紧张，因为她一直在摆弄念珠，她只是在说话。然后她不会扣安全带，所以我帮她扣安全带。所以在那个时候她对我说，我能请你帮个忙吗？我说，当然。她说，我能握住你的手吗？我觉得这有点尴尬，但我说，好吧，当然。所以我坐在靠窗的座位上。她坐在我的左边。所以我给了她我的左手。她用右手握得非常非常紧。
And this is before the plane has even taken off?
这甚至是在飞机起飞之前？
Yes. We're starting to taxi very slowly towards the runway. She had her rosary in her left hand, and she's holding my hand. And she had her eyes closed. And she was praying under her breath. I could hear her praying under her-- and it was like, Our Father. And then as the plane starts picking up speed and we're going down the runway, she just switches to saying, like, oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. And then as the wheels lift from the runway, you know you get that feeling a little bit in your stomach?
是的。我们开始非常缓慢地滑向跑道。她左手拿着念珠，握着我的手。她闭着眼睛。她在喃喃自语地祈祷。我能听到她在祈祷……是那种“我们的父亲”。然后当飞机开始加速，我们沿着跑道滑行时，她只是开始说，哦天哪。哦天哪。哦天哪。然后当机轮离开跑道时，你知道你胃里会有那种感觉吗？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
And she just turns around and bites me really hard in the forearm.
她直接转过身，狠狠地咬了我的前臂一下。
Wait. She bites you?
等等。她咬你？
Yeah. She lifted the hand that was holding my hand and bit into my forearm really hard.
是的。她举起握着我手的那只手，狠狠地咬进了我的前臂。
Where did she bite you?
她咬了你哪里？
Close to my elbow, kind of.
接近我的肘部，大概。
Oh, so like a meaty part of the arm.
哦，所以就像手臂上肉多的地方。
Yeah, yeah. And she didn't let go for a bit, so I was yelling. And she kind of had her teeth in me.
是的，是的。而且她咬住没放一会儿，所以我大叫起来。她的牙齿咬在我的肉里。
How hard did she bite you, would you say?
你会说她咬得有多用力？
So she did not break my skin. There was no blood.
她没有咬破我的皮肤。没有血。
Well, that's good. Would you say it was as hard as maybe you would need to bite into a soft piece of bread?
嗯，那很好。你会说它像你需要咬一口软面包那么用力吗？
More like an apple, I think.
我觉得更像一个苹果。
Oh, so some snap to it.
哦，所以有种咬合力。
Yeah. And it was quite sudden as well.
是的。而且也非常突然。
What do you do when she bites onto you?
当她咬住你时你怎么办？
I let out this really loud shout, like a yelp.
我发出一声非常响亮的喊叫，像是一声尖叫。
Understandable.
可以理解。
Not like a sustained yell, but a really loud ow kind of noise, loud enough that the people who are in the row in front of us and behind us and across from us all kind of turn around. I could see their heads turning in my direction to see what happened.
不是持续的尖叫，而是一种响亮的“哎哟”声，大到我们前排、后排和对面的人都转过身来。我能看到他们的头转向我的方向看发生了什么。
One of them had leaned over and seen that she was biting me and sort of shouted out, she's biting her! At which point, this lady let go, stopped biting me, and also let go of my hand and just started immediately apologizing profusely and saying, I don't know why I did that. I'm so sorry. I've never done that before. And I just kept saying, no, it's OK. Don't worry. It's fine. It's all fine. And she just kept going on and on, and that made it worse.
其中一人探过身来看到她在咬我，喊了一声，她咬她！在那一刻，这位女士放开了，停止了咬我，也放开了我的手，开始立即不停地道歉，说，我不知道我为什么要那样做。对不起。我从没做过那种事。我一直在说，不，没关系。别担心。没事的。一切都好。她只是不停地说，这让情况变得更糟。
And then the seatbelt signs go off, and it makes that plane noise. And a stewardess comes rushing to our seat and was like, what happened? And again, the person who had seen the bite leans over and says, that lady bit that girl. I didn't say anything. And the stewardess was like, is that true? And the lady goes, yes, yes, it's true. I bit her. And I wanted to say, like, no, nothing happened.
然后安全带标志关掉了，飞机发出那种噪音。一个空姐冲向我们的座位说，发生了什么？同样，那个看到咬人的人探过身来说，那个女士咬了那个女孩。我没说什么。空姐说，那是真的吗？那位女士说，是的，是的，是真的。我咬了她。我想说，不，什么都没发生。
Oh, no.
哦，不。
But the woman was confessing. She was like, no, I did it, and I don't know why I did it. And I'm so sorry I did it. I've never done that before. I felt embarrassed, in a way. And I don't like attention. I'm a fairly introverted person. So it was making me very uncomfortable. I just wanted to listen to my music and put on my sleeping mask and ignore all of this.
但那个女人在坦白。她说，不，我做了，我不知道我为什么要那样做。我很抱歉我那样做了。我从没做过那种事。我感到尴尬，从某种意义上说。我不喜欢引起注意。我是个相当内向的人。所以这让我非常不舒服。我只是想听音乐，戴上眼罩，忽略这一切。
The stewardess then says to me, can I speak to you privately? Sort of in the back of the airplane, in the galley where they keep their drinks and stuff. So I followed her back there. And she was like, look, do you want to report this incident? Because you have been sort of physically assaulted.
空姐随后对我说，我能和你私下谈谈吗？大概在飞机的后面，在他们放饮料的地方。所以我跟着她去了那里。她说，听着，你想报告这个事件吗？因为你受到了某种程度的身体攻击。
Oh my god.
哦，天哪。
So you do have the option, if we want. We can call the captain, and he will turn the plane around. And I just said to her, no, absolutely not. Don't worry. Everything is fine. But if you have another empty seat, maybe I could move?
所以如果你愿意，你确实可以选择。我们可以叫机长，他会掉转飞机。我对她说，不，绝对不行。别担心。一切都好。但如果你有另一个空位，也许我可以换个位置？
Oh. They had to have done that for you, right? They must have moved your seat?
哦。他们肯定为你做了那个，对吧？他们肯定移动了你的座位？
No. She was like, oh, the flight is fully booked.
没有。她说，哦，航班订满了。
No.
不。
And because I think I was a teenager as well, I just said, OK. I didn't argue the point. So then I just went back to my seat.
而且因为我想当时我还是个青少年，我只是说，好吧。我没争辩。所以我只是回到了座位上。
Can you remind me, how long is this flight again?
你能提醒我，这趟航班又是多久吗？
It's about 12 hours. And this all happened within the first few minutes of the flight.
大约12个小时。而且这一切发生在航班开始后的最初几分钟内。
That's so long.
那太久了。
It was a very long flight.
那是一次非常漫长的飞行。
So you're trapped next to her, basically. Like, you're stuck next to this woman who's bit you. What did that feel like?
所以你基本上被困在她旁边。就像，你被困在那个咬你的女人旁边。那感觉怎么样？
It was clear to me that she felt terrible and that she was still frightened. She did not sleep a wink on that flight. And neither did I. I could tell that she felt really bad. She was still praying and just sort of mumbling to herself quite a bit. Oh, this poor woman. She kind of coiled in on herself.
我清楚地感觉到她感觉非常糟糕，而且她仍然很害怕。她在飞行中连一眼都没睡。我也没睡。我能看出她感觉很不好。她一直在祈祷，还在喃喃自语。哦，这个可怜的女人。她蜷缩着身子。
And once I turned my back a little sideways, she did the same, sort of facing out into the aisle. So it was clear to me that she would not want more physical contact, or at least I felt that way. She didn't seem like a threat.
一旦我把背稍微侧过来，她也做了同样的事，面对着过道。所以很清楚，她不会想要更多的身体接触，或者至少我是这样感觉的。她看起来不像是个威胁。
Did you make any conversation after that point?
在那之后你们有谈过话吗？
No, absolute silence the whole way.
没有，全程绝对沉默。
Were you tempted at all to say something?
你有没有想过要说点什么？
No. I couldn't think of what I would say.
没有。我想不出我会说什么。
As you were approaching landing, were you thinking that there might be an interaction moment or you might say something to each other?
当你们接近降落时，你有没有想过会有互动的时刻，或者你们可能会对彼此说点什么？
I thought she would apologize again. I really did. I thought that when she stood up, she would say, oh, and again, I'm so sorry. So I had my whole little "don't worry about it" spiel ready. But she really didn't. She just-- she took her time trying to get all her things back in her purse, and then she got up and left.
我想她会再次道歉。我真的这么想。我想当她站起来时，她会说，哦，再说一次，我很抱歉。所以我准备好了我那一套“别担心”的说辞。但她真的没有。她只是——她花时间试图把所有东西装回钱包里，然后她站起来离开了。
I got to boarding school. I had this really cool story to tell that no one else would have had. But the more I told it, the more uncomfortable I got. Because a lot of people's reactions were like, yeah, what a crazy woman. And what was she thinking? And I started kind of feeling bad for her. I kept thinking, what would it take for me to feel that scared that I would actually bite someone? And I had, at that point, never been that scared in my life.
我到了寄宿学校。我有一个没人能有的真的很酷的故事可以讲。但我讲的越多，我就越感到不舒服。因为很多人的反应是，是的，真是个疯狂的女人。她在想什么？我开始为她感到难过。我一直想，我需要感到多害怕才会真的去咬人？而且当时，我这辈子还没那么害怕过。
I mean, how do you think about her now?
我是说，你现在怎么想她？
There's a kind of almost, like, fondness there.
那里面有一种几乎像是……喜爱的东西。
Isn't that funny how sometimes, when you get stuck in a situation with someone, especially something that's hard or long, that stuckness makes you feel like you're comrades, almost, or like you were--
当你和某人陷入困境，特别是那种艰难或漫长的情况时，那种被困感让你觉得你们几乎是同志，或者你们……这不是很滑稽吗？
Yeah.
是的。
You shared something.
你们分享了一些东西。
Yeah. And we shared something very unusual. It was just a very bizarre set of circumstances.
是的。而且我们分享了一些非常不同寻常的东西。那只是一系列非常离奇的环境。
Leticia Lima talking to Tobin Low, who's a producer on our show.
莱蒂西亚·利马与托宾·洛谈话，他是我们节目的制片人。
Our program today was produced by Dana Chivvis, who also produced Ayman's story in act one and Eileen's story in act two. Ira Glass edited the show. The people who put together today's program include Phia Bennin, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Adriene Lilly, Seth Lind, Molly Marcello, Andrea Marks, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Isabel Ruehl, Ruby Schwartz, Alissa Shipp, Ike Sriskandarajah, Christopher Swetala, Daphne Tolis, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Senior editor-- Nancy Updike. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们今天的节目由达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）制作，她也制作了第一幕中艾曼的故事和第二幕中艾琳的故事。艾拉·格拉斯编辑了这个节目。制作今天节目的人包括菲亚·贝宁、卡西·豪利、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯、阿德里安·莉莉、赛斯·林德、莫莉·马塞洛、安德里亚·马克斯、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·纳尔逊、纳迪亚·雷曼、伊莎贝尔·鲁尔、鲁比·施瓦茨、阿丽莎·希普、艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、达芙妮·托利斯和黛安·吴。我们的主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。高级编辑——南希·厄普代克。我们的执行主编是埃马努埃莱·贝里。
Special thanks today to Katrin Hansing, Michael Bustamante, and Matthew Steinberg. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of nearly 900 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our show's host, Ira Glass, who mysteriously took off for a few weeks. And then I ran into him behind the counter of a Starbucks. He seemed happy.
今天特别感谢卡特琳·汉辛、迈克尔·布斯塔曼特和马修·斯坦伯格。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费播放我们近900集的档案。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心传送给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的主持人艾拉·格拉斯，他神秘地休了几周假。然后我在一家星巴克的柜台后面遇到了他。他看起来很高兴。
Part-time job.
兼职工作。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm David Kestenbaum. Ira will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。艾拉将于下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。